Dragons have been a part of many myths
and folklore all around the world
whether they were a part of our
ancestors vivid imagination or ingrained
in our brains
the fear reptilian creatures along our
timeline of evolution is up to debate
some of the Dragons like smoke and
dragged on from live-action movies and
shows are shown to be frightening and
terribly magnificent but what about the
dragons from animated flicks in this
video we shall be showcasing to you the
dragons from the TV animated series and
movies of the franchise of How to Train
Your Dragon and this list will be all
about the 10 biggest dragons from that
franchise and included with the lists
are the size abilities and appearances
so here we go number 10 the fireworm
Queen this queen dragon of the race of
stoker-class fireworm dragons was first
seen in Dragons riders of Berk
fireworm queens of princesses looks
similar in appearance to the average
fireworm but have some differences that
make them stand out from the rest for
instance while the common fireworm can
fit in the palm of a hand the queen is
many times bigger when not heated up or
near an S the fireworm Queen snarls skin
color is a pale gold with tan colored
horn spots and underbelly she also
doesn't glow at the state all fire ones
can heat up their skin to a temperature
expressed to be hotter than the Sun hot
enough to be able to burn almost
anything fireworm Queen Tsar very
powerful bright napalm type fire breaths
that emits small firework like particles
these Queens are 89 feet long which is
27 meters and weigh more than two point
seven tons number nine the whispering
death at the next spot comes to weirdly
shaped dragons called the whispering
death these are a glass of bola type
dragons that are first mentioned in the
first HD t yd movie they are very
destructive and aggressive in nature
attacking anything in their way and are
generally feared by everyone they
usually live in underground tunnels
where they bury themselves using
a burrowing attack against enemy or prey
they have big heads with small wings and
rows of spines everywhere and also have
a very long tail that swirls in a
circular motion aside from their super
strong teeth and jaw muscles they can
also shoot out their spines as an
offensive move they can breathe hot
circular rings of fire and are very
agile durable and intelligent these
dragons heads are over seven feet tall
but their length is 95 feet long or 29
meters and weigh close to one tonne
number eight the scauldron the Scout
runs are mostly considered as non fire
breathers but they seemingly possess
sources of heat other than the body
temperatures that are most likely remind
us of their terrestrial or ancestral
abilities first referred to by Fishlegs
in the first movie as having the ability
to spew out hot scalding water these
dragons made their debut in the riders
of Berk this dragon species is an
aquatic title class dragon this dragon
is gigantic growing up to a size nearly
the same as many giant cetaceans they
have the ability to heat the water they
suck in its tail is like that of a fish
helping it to swim when filled with
water the scauldron stomach protrudes
out and becomes very round its neck is
very long and thin and its head it's
usually fairly slender with the bottom
jaw having some sort of a pouch that
hangs from its chin they weigh in more
than 1.3 tons and are 102 feet long or
31 meters number seven the typhoomerang
this is a stoker-class dragons at first
appeared in the writers of birth they
are very large dragons and they come in
a variety of colors including blue
yellow red and orange they have two very
large horns and orange eyes the legs are
exactly like that of a monstrous
nightmare they look like a mixed breed
of a monstrous nightmare and a timber
jack the typhoomerang is fiery breaths
resembles a giant tornado that who can
burn anything in his path except for
those that remain right in the middle of
it they are capable of spewing large
ropes of fire reaching several dozen
meters in length
typhoomerang possess immense strength
which combined with their large size and
weight make them one of the strongest
non alpha dragons known to Vikings
these dragons can grow to a length of
128 feet or 39 metres long and have a
wingspan of over 200 feet wide from tip
to tip number six the SUP Mareeba the
next one on the list is a gigantic
deep-sea dragon that creates whirlpools
and tidal waves to bring prey down to
its waiting jaws the submarine is a
large tidal class dragon and also track
a class dragon their first appear in
dragons raised to the edge the summer if
ur can be recognized by distinctive
foul-smelling bubbles that appear when
it draws near it reacts to vibrations in
the water above it and will follow them
in the hopes of encountering food the
submarine has proven to be an extremely
strong dragon because it was able to
take on a titan wing shell fire by using
a full body tackle on the large dragon
the summer Ripper can be best described
as being similar in appearance to an eel
with legs it is close to 150 feet of 45
metres long even though some websites
tape it to be only 50 feet long which
are wrong number five shell fire a large
tidal class dragon that first appeared
in dragons raised to the edge the shell
fire is an enormous deep sea dweller
with a crustacean appearance the shell
fire glides to the ocean had incredible
speeds and toes the dragon hunter
battleship bolted to its back the shell
fire is a gigantic titan wing deep-sea
dragon with a flat hot back shell for
protection
the shell fire can launched huge flaming
boulders that explode like giant
cannonballs
it has two long slightly curved horns on
the sides of its head shell fires are
capable of shooting a series of large
plasma shot boulders these projectiles
can be fired in rapid succession like a
mortar and hit like bomb shells the
shell fires armored carapace is so
durable and resistant that it enables it
to endure almost anything even numerous
blows from its natural enemy the
Submariner showing no signs of injury
only slight irritation
these dragons are over 160 feet are
almost 49 metres long number 4 the
screaming death this scary boulder class
dragon is a gigantic heavy mutated
whispering death according to Fishlegs
it is not documented in the book
of dragons as it is born every 100 years
or so the screaming death has all the
strengths of its subordinate cousin
their whispering depth with none of its
weaknesses as it can fly in the day
without being hurt by the light it is
the most powerful Dragon Berk has ever
faced since the Red Death
like the whispering death the screaming
depth likes to tunnel consuming sea
stacks and decimating entire islands it
is white in color has large red eyes a
longer and more massive body and a large
tail despite the screaming death sighs
its wings are only the size of a skull
runs some websites under estimated size
at only 50 feet long but they are
clearly wrong as we estimated them to be
between 200 and 300 feet long or between
60 and 90 meters number three the Red
Death
this enormous species is the main
antagonist of the first How to Train
Your Dragon film the Red Death is a
gigantic dragon her head is heavily
armed with a nasal horn a coral shaped
frill with jaws that are lined up with
huge salt like teeth the Red Death
possesses three pairs of eyes that gives
it little to no blind spots her
coloration is mainly blue with orange
unassigned
and his enormous body sports coral like
spines as well as red spikes and a Club
jail the rare deaths meeting bass flame
Jets are enormous and are powerful
enough to take down an entire fleet of
Viking ships in just one breath her
entire body is heavily armored with
dense scales horns and coral like frills
and evening the Titanic Beast to
perforate Pierce and demolish enormous
rock cliffs of the volcano and smaller
mountains on the sides according to
legend she lives for 2,000 years and
could grow up to four feet in length and
also has subspecies like the green and a
violent death at number two the forever
wing this is a gigantic mystery class
dragon that first appeared in dragons
the rise of Berk the forever wing is a
colossal dragon it has a woody brown
color and what seems to be like branches
at the back of its head and below its
chin these branch like objects resemble
hair and a beard with small kind eyes
and an agent appearance this dragon
looks rather old and wise the forever
wing has thick foliage such as trees and
vegetation on its back
the forever wing produces copious
amounts of lava which is powerful enough
to destroy entire villages in addition
to lava the forever wing is able to
shoot small glass of green acid as
revealed in dragon's Titan uprising
these blasts require less energy than
lava but are much more weaker than it
it also looks similar to a turtle this
dragon is truly gigantic in science but
since its size was never stated we can
only estimate it to be a little bit
bigger or at the same size with a red
depth at over 400 feet long over 122
meters and number one the B wildebeest
and the apex of a dragon's hives
chain-of-command rules an exceedingly
large and rare alpha dragon to which all
others bow to this is the B wildebeest
it is a gigantic title class dragon that
first appeared in how to train a dragon
part 2 we will the bees are incredibly
massive spiky dragons with a pair of
massive tusks like horns protruding from
its sights of the head and huge multiple
wings the front side of their bodies are
covered with burrs shaped like spikes
along with two lines of spikes along the
eyelets giving an impression of eyebrows
and we will the beasts most notable and
feared ability is to burst streams of
ice turning water on contact it does
this by sucking up and ingesting masses
of water from the sea and stirring it in
the goiters down its neck although it is
the king of all dragons and alpha
species it cannot fly but can swim and
stay underwater for extended periods of
time this Leviathan is the biggest
dragon species and measures 520 feet
long or 150 8.5 meters B wildebeests are
also quite impressive architects
fashioning near impenetrable nests for
their flocks or hive and with that we
come to the end of the list
do you like share and subscribe for more
related content on monstrous kaiju
screeches dragons and more